we begin with fast-moving developments
about the coronavirus including the
first reported death in canada an
elderly man in british columbia a
resident in a care home has died of
covid 19. it was a deadly turning point
for public health in the
the finger pointing began as soon as the
body started being carried out of the
residence 31 deaths in a couple of weeks
that's something very urgent the
coronavirus spread like wildfire
residents were dying in their beds more
than sixteen thousand long-term care
residents in canada lost their lives to
covet nineteen
fast forward to today and one thing has
changed thanks to vaccines the death
rate from covet in care homes has
plummeted what remains a crisis though
is staffing there was a shortage before
and the pandemic has made it worse
to get a clearer picture i met with
karen biggs she's a registered nurse and
ceo of meadow place in abbotsford bc one
of the largest seniors care campuses in
the province
for her the job isn't just professional
it's personal
hey sweetie you're going to be on tv
karen biggs has worked in geriatric care
for years and has done it all or she
thought she had then the pandemic hit i
can honestly say that in my 46 years of
nursing it's been the hardest time of my
career so this is that oh it is she runs
meno place a sprawling campus of six
buildings that offers multiple levels of
care from independent living to 24 7
nursing home care to 700 people
including peter he is karen's husband
peter moved in here in july and i had
had him at home and i found the care was
too much for me at the time peter
collapsed two and a half months after
their wedding in early 2020.
he had a brain tumor
after surgery to remove it he got
covered in the hospital
karen was living a nightmare trying to
keep him and all the residents in the
place she worked alive it would break my
heart when i saw people coming to our
windows to wave at their parents
everyone went into strict isolation some
families she said complained meno place
which long prided itself on being warm
and welcoming became like a prison we
had to hold families away
which was very hurtful for for us and
for the families and and we we wore the
wrath of many families because they
didn't understand you know why are you
not letting us come to see our loved
ones and what's it been like for staff
it's been really hard for staff we had
the single site order we lost 39 staff
to that the single site order prohibited
staff from working in multiple care
homes something that was common before
covid for nine months they held on and
kept covet out of meadow place
then like a ghost it appeared you'll
know in those days we didn't know that
it was airborne
and so it started with one resident who
came back from the acute care hospital
covered positive and we didn't know
because she was only there five hours
and every two days we got another
positive and another positive and
another positive
and at the end of that one
we had lost 16 dear seniors it was
profoundly upsetting to us
because you're so attached to the
residents you know they become your
family and in those days we had no
visitors
so our staff were the only people that
were seeing those seniors even when they
were dying
even when they were dying in those days
25 staff also got covered the shortage
was so acute patient care suffered
bathing was less frequent residents were
left in bed all day karen a problem
solver had an idea why not hire and pay
family members of residence i was
absolutely desperate because at that
time we had an outbreak and we had to
put in extra enhanced cleaning and we
just we just didn't have anybody she
ended up hiring nine family members you
went through
some terrible times the staffing
shortage still exists it got worse
you'll remember and that's what the
protests are about right now you
remember mandatory vaccinations so we
then again
lost nine regulars and 29 casuals
because we had people who refused to get
the vaccine
what did some of the staff
who refused to be vaccinated tell you
about their reasons i talked to one lpn
at least 10 times myself as the ceo
trying to get her to stay because she
was a really good caregiver of my
husband this is a licensed practical
nurse right who and she looked after
your husband yeah and she was so kind
and i did not want to see her leave and
she was a single mom
and so i tried every argument in the
book and she said no i read something
that a doctor in the united states put
on facebook
that it's going to alter my dna
and i said well you know there's many
learned people that don't believe that
way and i would just urge you to read
what they've written
but i couldn't convince her i couldn't
convince her that that one story wasn't
the true story
i actually support the position for
mandatory vaccination because the risk
is too great for our seniors we had an
outbreak last september on a unit where
everybody was double vaccinated the good
thing is we didn't have people die this
time what did losing those staff do to
care for residents
well it definitely added pressure on all
the all the staff that were left people
work overtime even when they don't want
to because they can't leave their
colleagues to be working short and they
can't leave the care not to be done we
have a full-time recruiter that we've
had for a year and a half now we've
recruited 222 people in the last year
but we're still desperately short the
hardest to recruit she says are not
personal support workers it's nurses she
doesn't think pay is the problem at
least not in bc the salaries are
excellent you know if you look as i
carry they're making twenty five dollars
an hour you know our nurses are making
uh probably about 55 an hour and the
benefits are amazing so karen what's the
solution here to recruiting one of the
mandates that we've been pushing in the
federal government is to try to make it
easier for internationally trained
nurses to come to canada
we have got wonderful internationally
trained nurses working as carried
because they can't get the paperwork
through to work as nurses here in canada
how acute is this staffing shortage more
broadly beyond your facility well it's
not only our province it's national you
know when i do accreditation surveying
in ontario and quebec and alberta's just
in the same situation the pandemic she
says may have scared people away from
working in care homes and has burned out
nurses everywhere what would you say to
them to
make long-term care and appealing
career the
rewards of working with seniors are are
absolutely immense if you love people if
you love stories if you love
hearing about the wonderful things that
they've done with their lives we weep
when they're sick we weep when they die
you know we become their family and
that's a precious precious gift you know
finish having your lunch one blessing of
having her husband at the care home
karen says is that she has him close by
every day the challenges aren't over but
he's starting to eat he's starting to
talk and hopefully one day he'll get him
walking again okay sweetie pie i have to
go to a meeting
give me a hug
you know she's constantly working on
solutions knowing the need for carers
will only grow as we all get
older love you